robin is bisexual let's go
this is one robin i believe that this is
like in the multiverse yeah i think so
um
he's bi
i kind of always felt that though what
does that mean yeah we always thought
robin was gay so bi is is
actually less progressive aggressive
yeah yeah
what is but what's the deal like why
what's why do why is this an
announcement she said i read the author
said something to the effect of like you
know i just started the character just
started speaking for himself and that
[ __ ]
i just let the words come out of his
mouth and he was bisexual yeah that's
such a weird one yeah only a [ __ ]
writer would say something that's stupid
but what is it like why do you see him
hooking up with guys and girls accepts a
date from a guy yes that's it yeah but
at that point i'm like just make him gay
why does he have a storyline
is it a robin
is like is it a robin comic
or is he within batman i think he's
within batman cut it
just cut it why does he have a story
line nobody cares about robin because
you got to come out with issues all the
time these comic books when did marvel
become so [ __ ] woke
this is dcc
oh [ __ ] yeah when did comics become
i don't know
there's like comic books comic comics
comedians
yeah there's also a history of comic
books also they've been like anti-war
anti-war they'd like to dealt with aids
things but yeah there's like some
anti-capitalism [ __ ] like really yeah
comics have always been like a little
bit on the progressive front
i mean these comics written by nerdy ass
scrawny jews and like wish fulfillment
of like being bullied moving to america
from nazis that's right
also i think a woke person would write a
much better bad guy someone who's not
woke he's this guy's going to be a piece
of [ __ ] thanos is an ill-ass bad guy
because you're like i kind of have
empathy for this guy the way he's
written you have whoever created thanos
had empathy for like a bad guy let's
make a bad guy that's a little bit
complex he just has a plan that doesn't
it's not the worst plan you've ever
heard to fix everything it's a solution
daredevil i remember watching that
marvel show that it wasn't great but the
bad guy was great because you really
like empathizing with him kingpin he
came from like a [ __ ] [ __ ] home and
they really paint his picture in a way
that gives you empathy for him only a
woke person is going to do that why why
why is this because a conservative like
not woke person doesn't have any empathy
for a criminal that's a criminal kill
him i don't give a [ __ ] but what if you
get the conservative to write that
character as if they're the hero and
then just take the script away from them
so it's like it's like what is the best
way to solve world hunger well if we
just had half the people then there'd be
twice as much food and then people
wouldn't be hungry thank you very much
that'd be great and
we'll just finish this off here
that's what you do
you get the extreme conservative to
write the villains as if they're heroes
that's what they do at the uh red school
they got a conservative they're like all
right who's the good guy they're like i
think jordan peterson yeah we're gonna
make him like he's gonna reach out to
young men he's gonna like help them he's
gonna change their lives and they're
like okay we'll take that
coach was like he's the bad guy yeah
yeah oh that's the strategy you got to
write the villain as if he's the hero
yeah
and that's why it works you could look
at every single one i bet you kingpin
was some like real estate mogul just
trying to revitalize hell's kitchen
right like this is a shitty neighborhood
we gotta bring it back we gotta get rid
of the crap get rid of the riffraff what
are we doing there's so much
the joker yeah the joker i'm still it's
like i don't really know why he's good
but people love him people love the
joker yeah yeah but yeah it's almost
like uh
a conservative didn't write that one
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just too crazy
but people still love them though yeah
they we do like why is he so [ __ ]
great he's the best it's pure chaos no
motive
yeah there's something there's something
really
intoxicating about uh somebody who
doesn't want anything but chaos he loves
his craft yeah i still remember the line
from the dark knight gotham deserves a
better class of criminal i think is what
he says yeah and he just burns the money
and he's like man
that's [ __ ] cool he's unreasonable
he's not negotiable i want it he's a
purist yeah well batman and and the
joker respect each other well they have
like the perfect relationship yeah
because the joker stops once batman
breaks his code
so it's like if batman all the joker
wants is for batman to break yeah it's
just like i want you to prove that
you're full of [ __ ] yeah so you just
kill me and i'll stop i won't do
anything just kill somebody i just want
you to kill yeah and batman's like i
can't kill so he can stop the joker
immediately yeah all you gotta do is
just kill him yeah he just refuses kind
of selfish brother real stupid selfish
real [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy just kill
him yeah yeah dude
come on do that man and nobody would
care nobody knows who you are
ugh you're saving lives
you're saving way more lives this way
maybe batman's good dude
you say what maybe batman's gay yeah
like constantly flaunting like oh look
how many women i'm gonna yacht with
he's positive
he wears the mascara and [ __ ] all over
how's he so rich gay
dueling duel incumbent
and what that's a very common
relationship with gays right you have
like the older man yeah kind of mentor
yeah oh my god annie was an orphan so
alfin groomed him up groomed him groomed
him up
whoa
he won't eat [ __ ]
he definitely won't be [ __ ] catwoman he
wasn't about it no he remember they
tried to have him go down on the girl
and they said something like superheroes
don't do that yeah yeah [ __ ] batman
yeah remember that when the character is
speaking for himself and then you cut
that [ __ ] out do you remember that now
robin's over here smoking [ __ ] yeah
isn't that crazy make robin full gay
that's what i want yeah just go all in
why is he bi like that that's so soft
yeah maybe his i guess his name is bi in
it but other than that there's no other
reason why you shouldn't be full guests
yeah
yeah why aren't they making him full
[ __ ] gay yeah
gotta go gay man there's no gay
superheroes yeah i was thinking maybe
they wanted to represent everybody like
to be more inclusive yeah but
there's no gay superhero start there
yeah and do they not know that we
consider bi people gay
they gotta they gotta pretend we don't
isn't that interesting yeah like when
anybody says to you yeah i'm bi you're
like oh you're gay
but unless it's a girl and then you're
like oh you're straight you're just like
attention
right like isn't that crazy like
bi girls we think are straight and one
attention bye dudes we're like you are
gay yeah you're in denial and you're in
denial full denial yeah
wow
i mean let's i mean do you guys believe
in in buy
for guys yeah yeah probably
i don't wait why
because if you were i think you would
just choose the side that was easiest
for your life so then they hook up with
guys no girls societally it's easier way
less scrutiny yeah but of the society
but if you're like i'm trying to get my
dick sucked i'll get up from a guy or a
girl you get a guy to do it yesterday
you know what i mean like yeah but maybe
you just want your odds to be the
highest yeah 100 i think that that
could exist but i think like most your
day is not spent [ __ ] yeah right most
days you know you're at work you have a
friend group you have your family and
all them could reject you if you're gay
yeah right so you're like i don't want
to give up all that for some [ __ ] i only
half like
i like it just as much as other [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean it's like
somebody asked me you want to eat bread
or rice and i'm like hold on the rice i
am way skinnier i'm gonna go rice right
it was easy for me to give up bread i
love bread i'm bi
i am bi for bread yeah but i was able to
give it up because my life was way
easier if i just live the right uh if i
just eat the rice so then they're real
say what you're making i'm a baguette i
love some baguettes bro why don't we
call girls baguettes you said that i
have okay good that's why i said it the
call back
[ __ ] two years ago
um but yeah that's i mean this is just
such a no-brainer yeah yeah
robin's gay dude robinson by gay i mean
by
i don't think that he won't come out as
full gay because he's worried what
batman will think yeah that's really
what it is 100 that's what it is he
doesn't want to let batman down yeah
because batman no batman just thinks
he's gay batman's like bro you've been
gay from the jump yeah
that's like karate so you could defend
yourself
do something i make you wear underwear
outside your pants for a reason dude
like come on keep your butthole covered
dude i know you put some [ __ ] zip tie
in there so you could open up that giggy
hole any time
robin wears full ass pantyhose he does
wear pantyhose yeah some little
bitch-ass [ __ ] for no reason about it no
whoa
yeah robin dude
yeah gymnastics come on oh is that what
he came from yeah i don't know from the
traffic background
from the trapeze at the circus
gymnastics he's a circus kid yeah yeah
he's a freak
but theater kids are always gay that
makes sense yeah but he's not theaters
he's carnival because the card
yeah it is uh
basically the same thing yeah how is it
yeah are we talking cirque du soleil
we're talking traveling carnies is robin
asian
no well he does wear a mask he does this
over his eyes
oh my god dude
we don't know what he is yeah i keep
thinking of him as dark knight robin he
does have that asian haircut with the
side part all the way over he's [ __ ]
asian dude you don't think about chris
o'donnell uh
why is the george clooney batman robin
don't consider it the only robin that i
know is the one from dark knight dark
knight what's that actor joseph
gordon-levitt joseph gordon-levitt
that's the only one i know we never got
to be robin say again he never got to be
robin i know they teased that [ __ ] a
little bit
yeah definitely not gay but this robin
gay asian 100 percent
not bi gay asian full-on gay asian and
they gotta let him tell a story yeah
yeah they're trying to suppress this let
him write his own story
yeah they're trying to let him be
palatable
and he's gay so he'll write a good story
probably right you were bi though
as an asian
come on now no come on now i'm saying a
bye age like the lady boys is just the
ideal situation right oh yeah it is best
of both worlds serve it up the hottest
girls that have [ __ ] yes everything you
want mm-hmm maybe he's not bi he's just
been around so many ladyboys he just
said whoa
they know what they're doing the life
this is the life yeah uh-huh a hundred
percent served up on a t form yeah right
there testosterone
wow man robin is full gay i'm happy for
him me too
shout to you robin guys i hope your
character keeps speaking bro
[Applause]
you